all right uh here here we have a couple
I think we go to a couple quick
questions here but there people who are
uh asking uh good questions over
here so this is
from Ronald Weinberg um how did the
authors of the Gospel learn that Jesus
had a virgin birth why did he never
mention this to the Sanhedrin and the
Romans that he had a virgin birth seems
like manmade um I'm just going to you
thought that was a good question
no a good question in terms of if if
someone just has no idea um then you
know makes sense to to ask the question
and uh give an answer uh Sam you can
respond however you want I'm just going
to quote I'm just going to quote the
opening verses of the Gospel of Luke
yeah yeah Luke so Luke uh wrote a gospel
and uh in the book of Acts and here's
how he starts off his gospel he writes
in as much as many have undertaken to
compile an account of the things
accomplished Among Us just as they were
handed down to us by those who from the
beginning were eyewitnesses and Servants
of the word it seemed fitting for me as
well having investigated everything
carefully from the beginning to write it
out for you in consecutive order most
excellent Theophilus what does Luke say
he says Hey when I'm writing about
things I'm going to the eyewitnesses
says he's going to the eyewitnesses what
does Luke write about writes about the
Virgin birth so where would he got where
would he have gotten this information
Sam yeah in fact that's what I was going
to tell you as you turn there and you
read it I want to also comment go to
acts 21 read 18 David all the way to 26
Acts 21 18-26 here you're going to get
your answer where Luke would have been
getting his information but now before
you do do read it notice what he's
saying uh why did he Jesus never
mentioned the saner in Romans why would
he I mean you think about it here are
people who are unbelievers who have
condemned them to die and you want Jesus
say oh by the way not only am I God but
my Mommy gave birth to me while she was
a virgin is that really a serious that's
why I was laughing I don't mean to mock
the person but
seriously why would Jesus in the
presence of his enemy say hey guys I
know you hate my guts you already think
that I'm a blasphemer for claiming to be
the unique Divine Son of God and you're
about to condemn me to die I just want
to mention though maybe this will
convince you you know I was born of a
virgin will that convin you why would he
even want to talk about his virgin birth
what relevance does that have to do with
the mission of Christ now with that said
where do we get this information that
Jesus was conceived to and born from a
virgin Luke himself tells us that one of
the eyewitnesses that he would have
interviewed because he met him is James
the Lord's brother if you go to acts 21
read
18-26 and the following day Paul went in
with with us to James notice the us
there us and the following day Paul went
in with us to James and all the elders
were present after we had greeted them
he began to relate one by one the things
which God had done among the Gentiles
through his ministry and when they heard
it they began glorifying God and they
said to him you stop there David now
watch there okay Luke says I was there
accompanying Paul when we met James and
you don't need to guess which James
because James the brother of John was
already killed off in Acts 12 if you go
to acts 1212 it says Herod killed him so
it's not James the brother of John the
sons of Zeb it's James the brother of
Christ and he says I was there and I met
him so here is one of the sources for
Luke and who better than James to know
whether his beloved mother conceived
Jesus Christ as a virgin or that Jesus
was the progyny of Joseph so here you
have the sources from which we get this
information on the life of Christ it's
based on those who knew Jesus and knew
his family let alone the possibility
that he even interviewed Mary because we
have no indication that Mary had died at
the time of the composition of the book
of Acts in fact Luke does mention in
Acts 11:14 that Jesus's mother Mary was
there with his brothers waiting for
Jesus to pour out the Holy Spirit on his
beloved mother and his brothers acts
1:14 so you can make a strong case that
if Mary was alive Luke would have
interviewed her at the very least he
interviewed James the Lord's brother um
and uh given what we read in John about
behold your mother uh seems like uh and
and in Acts chapter 1 seems like she
would have been living in the the
Christian Community that uh Luke
repeatedly visits here so hope that hope
that answers your question of course if
you if you want to say sounds like it's
something that that someone just just
made up um well of course people can can
make things up and you don't want to
believe just anything but the the the
real basis for rejecting this would be
some sort of um maybe an anti-s
Supernatural bias where we just don't
want to believe in the Virgin birth so
it it sounds like something is made up
but uh Luke is claiming that he went to
eyewitnesses for his uh information and
he he is he is one of the people who
telling us about the Virgin birth and he
knew at least at least um uh Jesus
brothers so hope that answer your
question